part of the reason why tic toc's been so
different is because it really obviously
besides vine back in the day it really
brought back short form video so people
have learned how to capture attention
for 9 15 maybe 60 seconds but i think
most tick tockers are going to struggle
with that transition to long form
content versus someone like you who's an
expert in youtube i think you would
instantly be able to create that long
form content that retains attention but
for most people i recommend starting a
little bit shorter 15 seconds eight
seconds and then growing your way to 60
seconds as you learn how to engage an
audience retain attention and ultimately
think of enough cool things to say in
order to keep people paying attention
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres i'm your host of
this show and on this podcast we help
you grow your influence on youtube and
then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high profit online business
and man is vertical video everywhere i
feel like my iphone is only vertical
video now it's youtube shorts it's tick
tock it's instagram reels so we need to
start understanding you and i how to be
utilizing this for our business video is
not going anywhere and the virality of
this vertical video revolution well that
sounded cool okay the virality of this
vertical video red resolute
no that's not what it is the virality of
the vertical video revolution is
unstoppable so today we're diving into
tik tok one of the fastest growing apps
uh with vertical video right now and
rachel pederson is going to be our guest
on the show and we're going deep into
her strategy of how she's reaching
people around the world we're going into
her workflow of how she's creating so
much content and the best practices that
you entrepreneur need to be doing right
now to be making vertical video a staple
in your marketing so let's get into
today's featured conversation
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
i'm fired up for today's episode because
we're talking all about short form
vertical video yes tiktok and my guest
today has three powerful tips for us and
also repurposing short form vertical
video across multiple platforms but if
you haven't met her before rachel
peterson is a minnesota mom of three
she is a social media expert and today
she's gonna be breaking down some of her
her powerful tips um but as we kick it
off
tell a little bit about your backstory
because you know about 10 years ago your
life was very different than it is right
now completely different so 10 years ago
i was actually a single mom living on
welfare and food stamps renting one room
with my daughter
literally doing medical experiments to
pay for diapers giving blood plasma i
still have the scars to prove it
life looked completely different a
decade ago wow
and today you're a business owner with
incredible business team you're helping
people with social media courses
membership sites you're speaking you're
doing you're in the trenches helping
some personal brands with the kind of a
white glove agency type service and
you're hands on
seeing what's really working on social
you have a great youtube channel you're
active across all the platforms but
you're in love with tik tok why is that
ooh that's a really good question i like
tik tok because it's the first platform
where i felt like you can really just
be yourself whether that's nerdy goofy
silly dumb whatever it is you want to be
it seems that there's a space for that
on tick tock and i'm a pretty nerdy
goofy person i kind of make a fool of
myself a lot on tik tok and it's felt
like it was the first place where i
could really truly be myself and that
helped me to branch out with success
more so on every single other platform
but something else i really love about
tick tock is that it has its own culture
so people understand these collective
inside jokes and there are layers of
inside jokes almost like you have a
million besties that are all in on the
same exact stories and history wow and
when it comes to tick tock right now in
2022 what should we pay an attention to
i know my account we're new there
official think media because we've been
on youtube we've been in other places
we're doing a lot of repurposing um but
it just gave me a notification you can
now upload five minute videos i'm
talking to other people they've got 10
minutes and i know the max depending on
your account is 15. what is even
happening like what do you think about
the state of tick tock and organic reach
video length changing what do you see
coming up you know for someone like you
you would crush it with longer form
content but i'm going to be honest part
of the reason why tick tic-toc's been so
different is because it really obviously
besides vine back in the day it really
brought back short form video so people
have learned how to capture attention
for 9 15 maybe 60 seconds but i think
most tick-tockers are going to struggle
with that transition to long-form
content versus someone like you who's an
expert in youtube i think you would
instantly be able to create that
long-form content that retains attention
but for most people i recommend starting
a little bit shorter 15 seconds eight
seconds and then growing your way to 60
seconds as you learn how to engage an
audience retain attention and ultimately
think of enough cool things to say in
order to keep people paying attention
valuable okay let's talk about it three
tips and this is some stuff that we can
apply right now to grow on tick tock and
really short form vertical video in
general number one is hook value cta
break it down beautiful so there are
three essential parts to every tick tock
obviously there are some that are
exceptions so like inside jokes or goofy
videos those might be a little bit
different but for value content
educational content you really want to
focus first and foremost on the hook the
hook is those first five seconds of your
video as you probably know from hanging
out here uh but what i really loved was
geeking out over the copy behind a hook
that really pulls people in and makes
them want to watch until the end and
there's a fantastic book that really
supported me with this called great
leads by michael masterson amazing book
to help you understand the first 100
characters of any piece of content
every time that i really hyper focus on
the hook my content performs better and
often times people can actually take a
video that didn't do well put a new hook
on the front of it and totally
revitalize that video with a whole new
audience and ultimately that video could
take off
the second part that i really love is
value and i recommend that most people i
know we usually hear like hook story
call to action but i'm going to be
honest if you're anything like me i'm
not a super great storyteller like i'll
start telling a story and people like
okay what's next so it's a lot easier
for us to do value and i recommend three
five seven nine points of value the
reason behind that is uh dan ariely's
book predictably irrational people are
drawn towards odd numbers and specific
numbers so add in those three five seven
points of value before you get to the
call to action now with calls to action
i feel like a lot of people kind of
freak out and they're like what do i say
here like subscribe to my channel and
like this video and and love me and
please let's be friends forever like
they kind of it's nerve-wracking coming
up with a good cta so here's an easy one
that anyone can use on tick-tock follow
for more
that's it that's it
three words three words anyone can do it
so you deliver the value follow for more
and and then that's a reminder at the
end of the video so they don't just keep
swiping and you have the potential to
build your following how have you seen
your tick top growth using this formula
i've been using this formula for two
years now and what's wild is it took me
about eight years to grow to 175 000
instagram followers even uh including my
days before being a marketer
and it took me three years to grow to a
million followers on tick tock so it's
been exponential but it's also helped to
grow my youtube my instagram and my
communities wow man incredible results
and uh using the power of the hook value
and cta number two though
is that volume gives you
data break that down oh so a lot of
times people ask me rachel how much
should i post and the answer is kind of
like how long is a piece of string it
depends uh the truth is you learn the
most when you post more and so i'm a
huge fan of recognizing you can grow
with one video a day sometimes you can
grow with a couple videos a week but
you're not going to learn as much from
just speculating or sitting back and
scrolling on tiktok which is very easy
to do so i recommend like these three
formulas for people and these are not
actually like crazy complex formulas
it's just a simple recommendation so one
a day monday through friday take
weekends off and that's gonna give you
decent growth and decent feedback
if you do two to five a day you're going
to see a lot more growth but also you're
going to get some insights as to this is
a topic that blew up and other people
will be able to audit your account and
more easily tell you hey i noticed like
all of these ones tended to do well why
don't you do more like that and when you
do 10 a day generally speaking i notice
everything explodes when i do 10 a day
but i also learn the most and sometimes
i'll do stuff that's completely
unrelated to my niche
wow
and so volume gives you data it's a
whole nother angle than just feeling
like oh should i just post a lot and so
you're posting a lot so you can get
feedback and then
the next step is to
learn and then adapt right so then you
try to trim out the losers double down
on the winners absolutely just the other
day i was looking at someone's account
and it was easy for me at a glance to
see that every time they talked about a
certain topic which was allowances for
kids every time they talked about that
their videos took off so because they
followed a high frequency or a high
volume pace of posting patterns were
easy for me to detect and so i said why
don't you create some more videos about
kids allowance sure enough within 24
hours 38 000 views
pattern recognition
but you got to do volume to get there i
love that tip okay number three
domino content
which is repurposing
between one to five platforms i'm
excited to kind of unpack this one what
is the domino content first and then
let's break down the strategy of maybe
the life span of one piece of your
content that lives multiple places so
imagine there's like a whole line of
dominoes and one action step causes the
whole line to fall down i'm huge into
that anytime that something can set off
a chain of you know events that supports
growth or works in the background for me
the better especially because if you're
watching this you're probably busy i'm
busy you've got a lot going on too i
need my content to be more leveraged for
me than just one platform can give so
domino content is this idea of is there
a piece of content i can create that i
can repurpose to other platforms without
and this is the key without it feeling
completely off for that platform and so
that's where i come up with the concept
of domino
content now the example of domino
content this is my favorite workflow is
to record and tick talk and then i use
an app called snaptic.app which is
totally free it's on desktop don't get
the app the app doesn't work so on
desktop you can just strip the watermark
there are several others that work as
well it will slightly desync the audio
so heads up
and that can bother some people it
doesn't bother me very much because i'm
not a perfectionist sure so i remove the
watermark and i repurpose it to ig reels
for sure
youtube shorts most of the time not
always i'm kind of steering away from
posting all my content there but also
sometimes people have access to some
shorter form videos on like linkedin i
just got facebook reels and some people
have talked about how there's a
potential for it coming to twitter as
well so with one piece of content being
able to be repurposed on every platform
we've seen huge success with this and
case in point i uploaded one youtube
short that within almost 48 hours had
660 000 views specifically related to my
expertise on tick tock wow crazy on
instagram reels same thing it feels like
they're one of the biggest things that
are moving the needle on instagram right
now as long as that watermark is not
there and we've seen videos get millions
of views just being repurposed in 60
seconds so you
created a video first on tiktok sharing
tips social media tips in this case tips
on tick tock and then you
use the app again what was it called
snap tick dot app snap tick dot app on
your desktop strip the watermark and
then you posted that on youtube shorts
and reels
it got crazy views on youtube shorts
and it was one piece of content in
multiple places i'm curious
um kind of maybe pivoting but how do you
think about youtube
in terms of your strategy you love tic
toc you're very active there you're
starting natively there what's what's
your decision-making framework for what
tick-tocks
get repurposed to shorts now that's
changing a lot for me um when i first
started playing around with youtube
shorts i was like let's try everything
let's see what happens so i literally
this is actually you might cringe a
little i would pull 50 videos at a time
and just upload them all and be like
let's see what happens sure especially
because youtube corporate was like
please do we want it all and i was like
all right let's just try it and very
quickly i realized that not all views
are the same on youtube and while i
sometimes think eyeballs can be helpful
it's not always going to convert well to
people who actually want to watch the
content on your channel so while in the
past i would do everything and you can
see the evidence on my youtube channel
now i'm going to be more focused on
sharing specific videos that relate to
an up and coming video or a past video
that i've already created
got it so you're always thinking about
your audience first and you're thinking
about your youtube audience in a unique
way what's your your youtube posting
schedule i know the topic of this
podcast is tick tock but we gotta slip
some youtube stuff in there your youtube
channel is some place you're very active
so how what's your cadence there in
light of everything else up until the
last few months i was doing three to
five per week which is a high volume
strategy i think according to most
people and of all the same thing or
three to five total one was a short
three to five of the long form videos
okay i'm new to youtube shorts so i just
started testing it over the last few
months and it was it was really cool it
was a great experiment and i don't reco
i don't uh not recommend it but i will
say the way i was doing it wasn't my
favorite way for sustainability of the
channel but now we are posting one to
two like longer form videos one being 10
to 20 minutes each week and then one
being a full-on two-hour training with q
a and i've been liking that pace it
feels like i'm connecting more deeply
with people
with youtube shorts i'm probably going
to go back to about one a day my ideal
schedule would be like one per day
monday through friday that's long form
and one per day that's a youtube short
that correlates with the long form piece
so that's like 10 a day and then and
then is that a live show two ten a week
yeah that's ten a week
and then is that a live show that's the
two hour show because it has live q a it
does how do you go live what software do
you use currently i'm using restream
okay and i've been liking that so i use
it to go live on facebook and youtube
sometimes on my personal profile too
just depending on what the topic is and
that's been pretty good and now i'm
looking for something that can also
stream to tick tock as long as i can
have the slides or the presentation
available for the tick tock audience we
have tested it with having my tic toc
streaming as well and we've had
audiences of several hundred people
tuning in from tick tock watching the
training so it's a lot easier
is allowing that to be native
at least for facebook and youtube and
and then on
is it just a little vertical video on
tik-tok as opposed to something that
would be better like directly from your
phone i just streamed it directly from
my phone for now i've heard that ob on a
separate device yeah on a separate
device and i've heard that uh like obs
has some really good tick tock streaming
stuff going on but i haven't tested
what's going to work there it looks like
they're actually moving to a lot more
vertical
integrations for lives so i'm interested
to see how that'll work out man we're
getting into some geeky stuff here but
this is uh this is
awesome i love your three tips on tick
tock i know that we got to be leaning
into tik tok and one of my questions for
you is you know kind of related to what
we're feeling we really like to
encourage the think media podcast
community to identify the season they're
in there's the
you know so there's the side hustle
season and that could include kids
family school there's a solopreneur
season where now you're making enough
where you don't have a nine to five and
then there's really the scale season
where things get interesting and now you
have a team around you or someone
helping you repurposing content and if
you try to imitate someone else's output
in the wrong season it can really mess
you up because absolutely you're
comparing yourself to somebody else and
whatnot and you know we are
for ourselves personally the season
we're in of course with our team
and and scaling and wanting to put our
content everywhere
we we really want to lean into tick tock
i mean we are but i'm like man we got to
double down on short form
uh vertical video this year and even
next week i'm going to do a shoot day
where i i do a lot of kind of talking
head style turning you know uh just all
kinds of you know educational stuff
whatever all that to say i'm curious um
what you would encourage those listening
to make a framework moving forward when
you think about okay should i be going
live like you and doing 10 a week and
you know what i mean and so to discern
maybe some next steps i want to yeah i
love that pre-frame one thing i want to
share is that to create all of my
content i do 95 of my own content
creation it's a staple in my business
for me to do it myself at least in this
season uh i don't do my own video
editing for youtube in particular but
that's important to keep in mind it
takes me three to four hours per day to
create all my content for every single
platform so i just want to point that
out so that you recognize like i don't
have three to four hours and i love that
you brought that up so one of the things
i recommend is looking at three major
things number one is the platform that
i'm focusing on leveraged meaning i can
create a piece of content it's going to
be seen by multiple people either now or
in the future number two is it long-term
meaning a little bit different than like
instagram not to shade instagram at all
but like an instagram post can disappear
pretty quickly and that can be kind of
demoralizing when you see crickets and
then there's no resurgence of that
platform yes uh right we've all
experienced it and the third thing that
i look at is is this going to be a
platform that's searchable and that's
really raised uh been raising in the
ranks for me of importance so i
personally look at one of those three uh
those three criteria i look at youtube
and tick tock as two of the front
runners across all platforms there you
go and i mean i i love it you my heart
pitter-pattered
as as youtube for sure goes through
those three criteria and to your point
tick tock as well hence uh that just
double downs on on how much here at
think media we want to double down on
tick tock official think media on tick
tock if you haven't uh connected with us
over there want to see what we're doing
but the better follow would be rachel
because she's the one with a million
followers on tick tock and success
leaves clues and so uh shout it out
where can we connect with you where can
we follow you what handles and uh thank
you for your tips today thank you the
easiest places to connect with me are at
the mrs peterson on all social media
platforms or rachelpederson.com i'll
ease in a d in my last name
well i hope that that gave you some
inspiration to get started with vertical
video i know for me it is part of my
2022 strategy that i want to be putting
out short form content all over the
place so we can reach more people with
our message that video matters and i
hope that that is your next step as well
have you opened a tick tock yet are you
posting your reels yet are you making
youtube shorts this is your time to get
started and if you want to first figure
out how to dominate on youtube then
definitely check out our latest youtube
class at
thinkmasterclass.com sean or myself go
live every other week sharing our
strategies of how you can be dominating
on youtube right now you can register
today for that free class at
thinkmasterclass.com
now every single week i love to read
your reviews thank you for rating and
reviewing the podcast over on apple
podcast and today's review comes from
cam kama x e k m k
that's a mouthful
thank you so much for leaving this
review you said great podcast love all
the advice and tips to build your brand
this is a must listen thank you so much
for leaving that review i know it took
you know just a few minutes out of your
day to get over there to leave that and
it means the world to us that you would
rate and review this podcast share this
episode with a friend if you know
someone who needs to be dominating on
tick tock right now and i want to thank
you for being a consistent listener here
on our show we're growing so quickly and
it's because of you sharing this content
with a friend listening to the podcast
all over the place and subscribing on
the youtube channel if you're watching
this right now okay for listeners in the
cars isn't for you but you and me locked
in if you're watching this i need you to
subscribe to this show this is going to
help you grow your business grow your
youtube channel and grow your influence
online so make sure you subscribe here
on the podcast wherever you're listening
but definitely you youtubers who are
watching and not subscribing thanks for
being a part of what we're doing here at
think media and we'll catch you in the
next episode did you hear that growth
video live 2022 is back in person this
is your opportunity to network with
like-minded people just like you to make
friendships to make business
partnerships this is your opportunity to
get in the room you can get your ticket
now at growethvideolive.com
they're going so fast so make sure you
get your ticket right now at
growthvideolive.com
[Music]
you